I'm gonna talk today about a tool in
canvas called Ally which some people
have had turned on but not everyone not
all faculty yet and basically this has
to come this has come out of a larger
initiative here at Yale to make websites
accessible this policy that Yale
published about a year ago was really
geared towards making sure that all
university websites are accessible for
people with disabilities and what a lot
of faculty and staff don't haven't
really been cued into yet is that this
also covers materials in canvas so you
can imagine in canvas every instructor
there's there are a lot of materials in
their course sites which may not be
fully accessible to students with
disabilities and we're really trying to
shift the landscape so that those
materials enter the canvas system more
accessible you can think of like PDFs
and Word docs and videos and Google
slide presentations just about anything
you ask your students to look at could
potentially present a barrier for a
student with the disability who needs to
be able to use different technologies to
access those materials and even within
those those materials there are like
smaller elements so we could just keep
breaking it down to like okay everything
but it's got images I have a
presentation that's got text and a video
player and a bunch of different elements
so how would a student who has a
disability access those materials that's
what a lie helps us with so I'm gonna
talk about that today
usually when I give this talk or I
present to people the first question is
I don't really understand what
accessibility even means for the
purposes of a lie today we're really
talking about materials that need to be
read by screen readers or text-to-speech
technology so faculty sometimes will say
well I don't have any students who use
screen readers because in their minds
the primary audience for that are people
who are blind or low vision who might
need to use a screen reader but at Yale
especially that's definitely not the
larger largest users of screen reading
technology here a lot of students with
dyslexia
screenreaders so you can imagine if you
have dyslexia and you have a hard time
following the words because they're
bouncing on the page they're bleeding
together it can be really helpful to
listen to your readings instead of
having to read them visually with your
eyes so the resource office on
disabilities will often suggest some
pretty easily operable screen readers
and text-to-speech technologies so
students can use those to read their
course documents same for attention
disorders again sometimes gonna be
easier just to listen some students
prefer that or to listen while you're
reading visually migraines concussions
there are about 100 students a year who
come through Yale who are diagnosed with
a concussion and if any of you have ever
taught a class or you had a student who
suddenly had a concussion and was told
not to look at a screen for any period
of time that can be very very very
detrimental to their semester i I've
seen students who just for weeks have
been told not to do their readings and
that can be impossible so just keep up
with their course materials the resource
office will often give them again a
pretty easily operable screen reader so
that they can lay on their dorm in their
residential College on the couch in the
dark and listen to their readings
multilingual students will use screen
readers there are a lot of students
international students especially who
may not have learned English by reading
it they may have learned at first by
speaking it and it can be useful for
them to have their text read along while
they're reading just to help them shore
up on their English language skills and
then write so that's four documents and
then as far as media goes really we're
talking about adding captionings for
your videos for deaf and hard-of-hearing
students and using audio descriptions
for blind and low-vision viewers as well
so I can talk about all of this stuff at
great length I mean there's so many
elements that go into making a course
accessible that they've created a
position for this today I'm really just
going to talk about a lie and what that
does in canvas to help make your
materials more inclusive so really if
you're thinking okay that's a lot of
stuff to think about where should I
start
PDFs number one thing we see in canvas
that can present the biggest barrier to
someone who's using a screen reader they
need to be ocr'd which stands for
optical character recognition and
basically that means your PDF goes from
a picture that a screen reader can't
read to a series of text and words that
a screen reader can read and also in
canvas your images should really have
alt text in image descriptions and I'm
going to talk a little bit about that
Alli is the tool you can see this is the
term accessibility which shorthand is a
11 y for the eleven letters between the
a and the y and that's where they get
the term ally so not only is it an ally
it's also clever so I'm gonna pull up so
I have a course that I've designed this
is anybody in this room can join this
course it's very intro to canvas course
accessibility and covers a lot of stuff
but what I want to show you today is oh
I'm not logged into this I need to be
logged in don't mind me
that's Brian's Ryan how do I log out
here we go
sorry I'll log in to mine bear with me
nope
is it just gonna keep Otto logging me in
sorry guys
yeah that's what he's doing
good idea
great thank you
I need to change my password don't tell
ya how many of you do this okay good
thanks not just me alright this is my
canvas instance right what I need to
show you is the files so in the files
section every single time what Ally does
is basically it's going to give you an
accessibility score for all of your
materials that can be very daunting if
you upload all a bunch of PDFs and you
realize I have a bunch of red dials I'm
failing miserably at accessibility don't
worry there are ways to fix it and
that's what's so great about this tool
when you click on a score it will tell
you the primary reason why that
documents failed so you can see here I
have a PDF and it says this PDF is
scanned which means basically it's an
image and it hasn't gone through that
OCR process I mentioned I have that same
document here basically another way you
can tell that something has not been OCR
is if you try to select select any of
the text it doesn't you know it doesn't
let you select the actual words so here
we have a PDF that is not OCR and that
means the student will not be able to
use a screen reader to read it the
option is here to download an
alternative format which will give you
an OCR PDF so students can see that they
have that option as well as instructors
you click download it will download I
didn't take chances with that so I do
have the version here and this is what
happens you can see it presents a much
cleaner version that now can the text
can be selected and so a student using a
screen reader can listen to the document
that's one of the like many many many
cool things that allied does but I
wanted to show you today you can also
really just kind of get a sense of your
own materials and the health the
accessibility health of your course by
looking through those dials which i
think is helpful there's also other
things that it will it will actually
scan one of those is images so if I
wanted to add an image say you're
building your course syllabus and you
want to add an image there's an
option there for you to add alt text so
whenever you upload a photo it will give
you the option to do that as well I have
a photo somewhere in here yeah I'm
looking there we go I have this nice
picture of this cat that's a very
popular cat I think I need to actually
add it to my file section first there we
go
Hamilton open and now if I wanted to add
that file
you can add alt text there so I could
say photo or image of moustached cat
whatever it is you can imagine in
Hamilton if it was decorative if you
just have an image that you don't really
need to have described you can also have
the option here to mark it as decorative
you put update here I have added it I'll
update my syllabus and now you'll see
that my little photo of Hamilton is
there and if someone using a screen
reader were to come across that image it
would announce whatever that alt text is
in the process of them encountering it
in the reading now if it's a chart or a
graph or something like that it's a
little bit more complicated you can also
add the alt text it can be really useful
to summarize the main points of a graph
or a chart I think we overestimate the
amount of time students use spend on
reading graphs and charts that
information can be there for someone who
might have a cognitive disability who's
using a screen reader and it helps
clarify for them if someone's low vision
and they're using a screen reader you
may think wow they can probably see it
it may be that the the size of the font
or the way that the graph or chart is
constructed is just too small for them
really to be able to have a good sense
of it so that also will give you a
little score it'll say perfect
it should say P u RR Fe CT and yeah
there's there's quite a bit of other
things that you could do to make your
courses more accessible but Alli is
truly the step that I think the
university is taking for the for the
time being on putting some of that
responsibility back on us so that
students don't need to wait request
materials all the things that they do
when they have accommodations that can
take time or they may not want tackle T
to know in the first place that they
have a disability yeah yes
convert a scanned document or do I have
to provide the new version No
so you you would you would have to re-up
load so you could download the oh sorry
version and then re-upload it yeah right
doctor yes you can that OCR documents
using an acrobat pro which is not a
canvas tool but i can show you how to do
that i'd be more than happy to meet with
any one of you to talk about how to make
all your course materials oh yeah there
I have a video I've got all kinds of
different things yeah told ya I'll be
here afterwards you can ask me questions
I have handouts I have business cards we
can talk other questions alright thanks
[Applause]